i'm elle fanning i'm nicholas holt and
we're here to take the buzzfeed co-star
quiz i have a terrible memory so this is
going to be quite challenging for me
pretty nervous
[Music]
okay they're full birthdays
so i remember i distinctly remember your
party
and i noticed whilst we were shooting
i think it's between
march and april uh-huh yeah yeah i'm
gonna go april yeah okay yeah and i'm
gonna go
april
9.
yes
i cannot believe i got that really yes
yes
it is wild okay so you get to check okay
darn okay i know that yours is in
december i think i have psychic power i
don't know i was like
i'm sending it to you geez
your heart racing okay guess mine okay
i know it's december and i think that
it's
between two
and i know it's a team
is it not
i know is it 19th 17th
18th
16th it might be quick if you count from
one
seven
their middle name you have a really
weird middle name it's like cognac or
something i prefer cognac
you know what that's the coaster
crocodile or something it is very yeah
it's correct wow athletic it's well [ __ ]
okay i think i get a check that's you're
close enough no one knows my middle name
uh your middle name is mary well it's
not your middle name right but that's
what is what your middle name would be
mary's girlfriend right yeah so my
middle name is yeah that was good but
you knew
so i know yeah yeah marielle you know
what i'm saying all right your dressing
room must have oh i know yours what's
mine tequila oh yeah
yeah you always have tequila i do it in
your trailer your little teddy bear no
teddy bear and my nintendo oh you know
mine you always have a candle you always
it always smells good in your trailer
okay yours is like a boy trailer yeah
mine's very boy you decorate yours
nicely but also you had those cushions
that i got you which i feel should
become a must-have i bought
on april 9th which i knew
of my face it's just a close-up of my
face
so i feel like that that's it that's
good and you know what
you are on it today because you know
what my aunts what i was going to say my
pillow because i always bring my pillow
go to activity between filming scenes
like we both have similar
snacking yeah so yeah you both get that
one right yeah coffee order you know
what this is interesting because
l is also my uh dietitian and
nutritionist while onset
so whatever else
eats or drinks i basically have as well
yeah and you discovered that uh crafty
could make kind of a frappuccino
anderson came in and she was having a
frappuccino i was like what so we both
have the same same order my normal
coffee order is an iced latte with oat
milk what is your coffee order i wasn't
planning to guide you straight nothing
in it black yeah yeah your first acting
gig uh your first was it i am sam
it was yeah you were iconic you said
this the other day it was a monster
thing is it going about monsters no
that's right i don't know
their acting medium preference film tv
commercial theater etc
at the moment i would say your
preference is tv
um yes i prefer in commercials because
you get paid better i don't know i think
you might be film at the moment it's a
lot of time tv you have to commit a lot
of time yeah a lot of months completely
right okay we're both right first time
you met the young ones
doing a film
in south africa called young ones i more
remember that on that shoot we all
stayed in like the same kind of
bed and breakfast and all had like big
dinners together we both get that one
the last project before the one you
worked on together was yours the tesla
film i can't remember
you can't remember
i can't remember what film
i did before oh no it's a challenger
thing no favorite
no oh god you just filmed
so much the film that i did before
okay you're the one before the pilot
yeah i know what it was i've got no idea
i know let me get the point here it was
maleficent the second one i should have
known that it's okay we both don't get
points there the person who visited the
most on set we're not really allowed any
visitors no not for covid so no one no
one my family didn't come the whole
entire time no but before the time
before i feel like your mum and sister
came yeah and spent time in london yeah
so i won't give myself the point i think
we get that point because technicality
yeah favorite snack and crap whatever
i'm eating whatever chicken wrap i was
gonna say chicken wrap favorite scene
you shot together from season two i
suppose yeah clitty bitty i know i
or is that just the one that first comes
to mind it's the one that first comes to
mind the dancing scene was actually it
was really sweet
to say that
we're psychic we both get that point
give a point the favorite movie okay i
know yours i think it's eternal sunshine
oh yeah you can yeah you can definitely
get a point right you really like that
one yeah i'm trying to think of mine
your favorite movie i have a lot i'm
weird give me one little clue just in
case i can be psychic again blonde mom
that's
wouldn't have guessed it sorry yeah
that's okay it's your hometown in
england like country
right
inside you didn't live in london no no
hometown's not london outside yeah
i don't know the name of it washing bird
or
washington
hampshire and iron
i was born in reading and you what is
your what is it georgia but not savannah
no like an hour's drive from that two
hours
longer than that three hours driving
yeah it depends how fast you're driving
con yours
you get that kanye's yeah i've got
hidden talent i know what you're going
to say darn it you know what i'm going
to say
uh elle can do uh a bridge
very well you know
back ben bridge where you're going to go
on your you don't know what bridges
hands back there and your feet from the
floor oh what's the secret talent you
have you're very
stunty like you do all the stunts and
you get into that you really like you
like all that do you like that you're
good at it liking stunting you like you
secret talent so we both get that show
me my results 12 out of 15. i got 13.
yeah you're better you reigned supreme
that birthday was because of the
birthday thing i genuinely can't get
over that thank you so much i am the
champion of the quiz we hope you enjoy
season two of the great thank you
buzzfeed
for all your great quizzes everybody do
so
like a void in my life